pour être honnête je là vous décidez
d'aller dans l'archipel des spratleys
quand tout le monde vous dit c'est
impossible
voilà qui nous a rendu encore plus
déterminés à y parvenir il s'agit selon
l'onu d'un des huit points chauds actuel
de la planète
un point chaud c'est une petite zone de
conflit potentiel capable d'embraser
tout un continent
[Musique]
pas de série pour les spratleys un seul
bateau qui fait la navette deux ou trois
fois l'an acheminant habitants ouvriers
et avitaillement depuis le continent
jusqu'à cette poignée de recife perdu
dans la mer de chine
mais au fait combien d'heures de route
pour les spratleys
trois heures ces trois jours nous
embarquons grâce à un certain rosendo
hellman tess se présentant comme le
maire de la plus vaste municipalité
outre mer des philippines
ma commune et dispersées sur un groupe
d'îles ou au beau milieu des spratleys
justement je vous y emmène à condition
de payer la moitié du gasoil
non
[Musique]
aux premières lueurs du jour la
silhouette d'un chalutier non philippins
apparemment au mouillage devant un petit
atoll inoccupés notre équipage pic
dessus sans hésiter
[Musique]
altintop
j'aurais fait comprendre de s'en aller
ils sont capables demain c'est dans ce
coin à plus de 1500 kilomètres de leurs
côtes
ces marins chinois sont venus prélever
poissons crustacés pour peser calamar
apparemment ici tout est permis pêche au
cyanure mais aussi à la dynamite ou
encore aux filets dérivants ce sont déjà
des eaux territoriales ici alors c'est
comme ça qu'on procède dès qu'on arrive
ils fichent le camp puis ont peur car la
compétition est terrible l'archipel des
spratleys nourrit plus de 350 millions
de riverains qui se disputent ce
territoire maritime grand comme cinq
fois la france
le vietnam les philippines taiwan un peu
l'indonésie et la malaisie
sans oublier le dernier une certaine
chine
du poisson dans les pattes l'est mais
aussi beaucoup de gaz et de pétrole
l'équivalent du koweit enfui sous les
atolls sous les récifs trésor
inexploitables tant qu'aucune autorité
compétente ne s'impose aux autres
le bateau municipal de rosendo se traîne
trop chargé il roule d'un bord à l'autre
on est assommés par la chaleur le bruit
du moteur
le mal de mer
dans l'après-midi une fine bande de
terre qui s'épaissit c'est l'îlot de la
wac l'une des sept îles qui composent la
municipalité du mayor sept-îles dans
cette région donc vaut mieux toucher
cette île en tout premier appareil point
de référence
ce premier mandat depuis le continent
les passagers vont débarquer se reposer
un peu toutes ces heures de mer ils se
sentent un peu chahuté nous nous
glissons dans le dinh dit en espérant
que l'autorité du major nous permettra
de débarquer sans autorisation sécurité
nationale
nous comptons aussi sur la compagnie de
dexter ex commandant de la navy et
surtout agents de renseignement
philippin engagé pour notre sécurité
lilo est cerné de récifs difficile à
franchir même par beau temps aucune
passe aucun chenal pour quoi faire
personne ne vient jamais
hélas
ban est arrivé là
thomas chabolle
n'est ce pas
alors
voilà
parler avec eux
l'accueil presque chaleureux nous étonne
dexter y retrouve par hasard son ami ray
avec qu'il a mené quelques opérations
commandos quelques années plus tôt
jamais nous n'aurions pu débarquer sens
la reine est pas censé parler à des
civils encore moins des étrangers c'est
dexter qui fait la conversation
explique-nous ce que tu fais depuis le
matin quand tu te réveilles dans l'après
midi tu vois ce que je fais tes journées
qu'on imagine
qu'est ce que tu veux que je te raconte
et qu'ils aient l'air sérieux à l'aube
ont fait notre tour de garde
on scrute les environs pendant deux
heures on rentre prendre un petit
déjeuner ensuite un peu de ménage
à midi on recommence là il faut juste
supporter la chaleur
le soir on se repasse dvd vers 21h 22h
on fait notre tournée on se couche une
paire d'heures vers 1h ou 2h c'est
reparti c'est la même chose alors on
essaie de dormir
oui
une île grande comme un terrain de
football une radio qui porte à quelques
milles des citernes d'eau depuis quatre
grands sacs de riz le poisson du récif
pour seule protéine ni fruits ni légumes
depuis 40 ans de braves soldats qui se
succèdent tous les trois mois à scruter
l'horizon
[Musique]
tu sais ce que c'est on peut pas
s'empêcher d'y penser à sa famille la
famille au loin et ça nous prend tiens
comme tout à l'heure quand j'ai vu ce
qu'il nous restait plus de bouteille de
rhum
vous allez jeter un coup d'oeil sur la
borne là bas les stones oui la pierre
lasbordes officielle qu'on a construit
la wii il ya très très longtemps pour
dire au monde qu'il s'agit d'une terres
revendiquées par le gouvernement
philippe malgré leurs prétentions
affichées
les philippins ne pourra empêcher leurs
voisins d'implanter dès les années 70
leurs propres positions militaires sur
des îlots voisins inoccupés post ici et
là des fortins maçonné à la hâte et
occupé par une poignée de soldats
chinois ou vietnamiens armés jusqu'aux
dents
la municipalité du mayor se transforme
de fait en une mosaïque de confettis
multicolores chacun place ses pions
formidable jeu de go
mais pour les pions comme ray abandonné
sur son caillou la moindre distraction
peut être fatale pourquoi est-ce qu'on
installe des gens comme nous ici pour
que l'histoire qui est arrivé entre
l'île de pucca délisle de parole à sa
voisine ne se reproduise plus avant les
deux il était contrôlée par des
philippins des marines comme nous un
jour les uns sont partis faire une
partie de basket chez les autres boire
un coup ou deux à leur retour des
vietnamiens s'y étaient installés les
nôtres n'ont jamais pu débarquer et on a
perdu l'île de barrow là comme ça
maintenant ça rigole plus on fait notre
mission
rien d'autre
[Musique]
les joueurs de go vous le diront toutes
les positions sont bonnes à prendre
pourvu qu'elles embarrassent
l'adversaire elle mayor frôle l'une
d'elle plutôt inattendu mais dites-moi
majorque est ce qui les a décidés à se
positionner ici qui se sont échoués
tout simplement parce que la passe pour
entrer dans le lagon et de l'autre côté
là bas ils sont passés par dessus la
barrière et on n'en ont pas fait le tour
contre mauvaise fortune bon coeur
cette vieille carcasse échoué par
accident fait depuis office de poste
militaire officiel mais malgré nos
efforts aucune réponse à nos appels
une nuit trop agitée peut-être les
distractions sont rares
après trois jours et trois nuits de mer
nous débarquons enfin pas gaza la
capitale des spratleys philippines ici
rosendo n'est plus seulement le premier
magistrat de pagasa il en devient le
grand metteur en scène
lille c'est son théâtre car une terre
émergée n'est rien selon le droit
maritime international
si elle ne peut témoigner d'une présence
humaine viable effective et continue si
c'est le cas c'est une île et si c'est
une île les 200 milles nautiques au tour
soit un cercle de 370 km lui
appartiennent poisson et pétrole compris
c'est vraiment super et silures
cristalline donne envie de se baigner
d'où l'idée de faire venir du monde
deux peuples et le décor mais attention
pas de figurants a pas gaza des
résidents
comment les convaincre de venir et de
rester ça c'est le boulot du maillot
pour commencer au vanneau salines sans
qu'un projet en cours d'expérimentation
mais c'est tout seul c'est nous qui le
produisent au sucre précieux le sel seul
conservateur des aliments sains de frigo
a pas gaza ici c'est la porcherie notre
ressource en viande sur leur faire vivre
des militaires à la dure c'est toujours
possible mais pour installer des civils
faut leur rendre la vie agréable à leur
rosendo a imaginé une petite société
idéale voilà c'est notre centrale
solaire de 10 kg avec quelques finitions
à pleuvoir on a déjà 120 panneaux de
vous avez trop d'idées pour sur une île
utopique qui iraient au devant de tous
les besoins de ses administrés pourtant
pas de télé pas de radio pas de
téléphone pas d'internet a pas gaza mais
le must de tout mairie qui se respecte
notre salle polyvalente avec un billard
pour les loisirs pour qu'il puisse dire
tout le temps c'est notre épicerie
municipal on peut sourire
mais pour le mayor plus son village fait
vrai plus les philippines prennent
racine seulement attention avec rosendo
c'est donnant donnant la plupart des
gens ici sont des employés communaux
excepté quelques pêcheurs pourquoi la
municipalité cette souvenirs à tous
leurs besoins assure lire une seule
condition ils doivent rester très bien
elle mayor sûr qu'à gaza il y a tout ce
qu'il faut
mais hormis des ouvriers occasionnels et
des élus de passage qui habite vraiment
cette île théâtre le bout du monde
seuls nous avons musarder dans les
parages jusqu'à tomber sur des mots
gracias et louisa pour le moment je
travaille comme assistant son mari mais
c'était rien on s'occupe du générateur
distribuer d'éclairage de lille l'a été
mais moi je suis chargé de faire
respecter les règles du village mais
celle dans la distribution de nourriture
le partage des corps belle et tout ça je
suis payé tous les mois environ 1000
pesos je suis donc ici se couvraient
c'est une école mais mais pas un seul
mètre on veut postuler à cause de
l'éloignement sa distance et le voyage
pour venir ici trop dangereux ils ont
peur
[Musique]
et toi là on vient en sécurité ici pas
de brigands pas de maraudeur la dépense
rien sauf si on a une contractuelle et
un électricien de fonctionnaires à mi
temps qui râlent un peu normal rosendo
pour l'instant voilà un peuplement des
plus classiques dans la soirée nous
suivons une nouvelle petite silhouette
qui semblent s'échapper du hameau les a
cinq enfants dont le dernier est né sur
l'île
ce n'est pas rien une première naissance
enregistrés à l'état civil de pagasa un
bon point pour rosendo c'est dexter qui
nous a signalé les a mais pour une autre
raison
[Musique]
cette frêle allure son oeil d'agents de
renseignement n'a identifié
immédiatement les as tu te souviens
comment on s'était rencontrés la
première fois apprenons les devenus amis
ensuite puis on s'est perdus de vue et
on se retrouve ici
oui la première fois sept en 2002
c'était un poste de police
ah non c'était chez vous oui dans notre
maison
oui c'est ça chez vous exact que vous
avez débarqué oui on était là lourde
pour vous surprendre à l'aube oui je
dormais encore à l'époque je ne voulais
plus lutter je m'attendais à être tué
j'étais sur la liste des ennemis publics
vous n'avez pas d'avenir au feeling ou
même pour nous les jeunes diplômés sans
appuis ouverts les yeux sur tout ça ils
m'ont aidé à voir la misère des gens
alors moi j'étais toi jeune innocente je
les ai suivis et puis je voulais vivre
une aventure et je me suis fait
embarquer
oui et c'est pour cela que je vous ai
amené ici kayodé n'a la réponse
le but c'était de vous protéger de vos
anciens amis gauchistes les à témoin
protégé mise au vert sur pas gaza
l'ancien activiste en cavale en
résidence surveillée est devenu
responsable du potager municipal une
planque contre des légumes
fallait y penser et rosendo square des
courges des poivrons des concombres des
haricots des choux chinois et même des
radis j'essaie de faire pousser tous que
cette herbe bien le faire germer
je crois que les gens de l'île après si
tous ces légumes qu'ils cultivent pour
[Musique]
j'ai appris à lille ce week en tong a
commencé inari à aimer notre mission est
parfois quand on va sur le continent
cette il nous manque
donc on y revient toujours nous
travaillons ici et ça fait vivre ma
famille
c'est pourquoi finalement nous sommes
vraiment plus réussi que sur le
continent nous sachant français et
curieux les gens de l'île nous encourage
à visiter la troisième maison du
lotissement numéro un de temps en temps
ça reste aux chandelles au matin
s'approche de l'avarié sauver celle ses
fans oui il sourit le voilà c'est figaro
à cela il faut savoir s'entendre avec
tout le monde ici si on veut rester en
ballon côté pas se laisser à la
mélancolie savoir s'occuper s'amuser si
on ne fait rien forcément on pense à sa
famille ses amis quand j'étais joueur
j'ai aussi eu un salaire mensuel
moi je m'occupais des déchets qui
traînent sur les plages c'était un
boulot là mais le soir cada je
retournais sur les plages m'occuper des
autorails les poneys
je fais ça pour m'amuser
[Musique]
ob nord sauf des tortues quand tous ici
se délecte de leurs ce home nord apprend
le français
personne ne sait pourquoi
[Musique]
oh
hop nord espèrent qu'une femme du
continent acceptera un jour de vivre
avec lui sur pas gaza
toutes ont refusé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
go
oh
[Musique]
en attendant hommes nord s'est lancé un
défi
[Applaudissements]
resté trois mois ici et retourner sur le
continent c'est facile ce que je veux
c'est battre un record et c'est cette
chorale écho à celle je veux devenir
celui qui est resté le plus longtemps
sur l'île c'est ça qu'on parie tête de
pont des philippines dans cet archipel
pas gaza accueille un maximum de corps
d'armes en représentation cinquante
militaires s'ajoute ainsi aux 50 civils
résidents sur le papier c'est
impressionnant mais à y regarder de plus
près on découvre une poignée de
garde-côtes 100 embarcations des forces
aériennes sans appareil des commandos
sans moyens d'intervention
soldat inoffensif peut-être mais qui
permettent à la fiction municipal de
continuer à ce jour
les voici les territoires occupés par
les philippines que l'on appelle aussi
municipalité décala yann chapeau aux
mayor ta troupe témoigne sur ce théâtre
nrg d'une présence viable effective et
continues tu l'a t'on il
mais à quelles conditions
as des meilleurs qu'en tant que maire de
la municipalité des canailles and one
day we propose un moment j'ai recommandé
qu'on établisse de bonnes relations avec
le voisin l'espanyol les chercheurs
personne ne souhaite jouer la
provocation nos bateaux aux lecteurs aux
banques depuis mais c'est aussi tout le
monde s'en tire sur ce statu quo onesta
tosco le bateau municipales sont
retourne vers le continent
combien de temps encore tiendra le statu
quo entre des états voisins
incapable de lâcher le moindre pouce de
terrain à leurs ambitions
de quelles alliances sont ils capables
pour exploiter raisonnablement les
richesses de cette mère dit de chine que
traverse quand même la moitié de tout le
trafic maritime commercial mondial
le meilleur atout le voyage de retour
pour y réfléchir
trois heures
et trois jours
[Musique]